é a primeira pergunta é o que vocês
acham que eu faço só olhando assim e se
esse perfil assim vocês acham
só vou dar uma adoraria
ontem eu vim fazer esse ensaio que eu
tinha que marcar o tempo da minha fala e
falei o porteiro em fazer um ensaio e
erro
não falei do que ele imediatamente você
vai dançar amanhã
não sinto muito não vou dançar
já fiz aula de dança dancei balé e tudo
mais mas não a primeira coisa eu sempre
amei matemática física gostava de
línguas também tinha muita facilidade em
aprender línguas sempre fui a primeira
da minha classe em todas as matérias
sempre me apaixonei pelo professor ou
professora importado sexo eu amarro
professor de matemática de física de
química amava
passei pelo ginásio na época ginásio bem
velhinha tá
passei pelo ginásio primeira aluna no
meu tempo tinha que fazer um exame de
admissão do ginásio colegial minha
segunda melhor nota
passei pelo colegial segunda aluna a
já entrei no liceu de artes e ofícios de
são paulo fiz o curso de técnico em
edificações segunda melhor nota
sendo que a primeira nota também era um
negro e não existia nem falava na
derrota
passei eu me formei em técnico em
edificações
é lógico que eu queria ser engenheira
civil não é técnicas onde atua dentro da
casa
bom eu queria fazer engenharia civil e
nunca vou conseguir não passei no
vestibular e pás em física
eu entrei em física na federal de são
carlos ainda o terceiro ano de física a
federal de são carlos abriu o curso de
engenharia civil eu fiz o vestibular de
novo mas nesse mesmo ano comecei a fazer
física quântica e semicondutores eu
tinha ofensores viega que era o máximo
em cênico foi muitos mas muitos anos
então semicondutor estava começando
então tinha uma pessoa que sabia muito
de semicondutores ele dava na minha
faculdade
ele começou a contar todas as
possibilidades que é isso que vocês têm
agora nas nossas bolsas que o cene
condutor poderia fazer
também com eletrônica eu estava nesse
meio aí foi paixão à primeira vista não
passei no vestibular de nené na federal
para a agenda se dilma não interessava
mais
me formei licenciatura ou retorna física
que quando terminar o curso de física
que você vai ser quando crescer
professor do colegial ram aí eu falei
vou fazer um mestrado
logo de cara já foi o mestrado em física
aplicada eu trabalhei com as células
solares a minha tese de mestrado foi
estudar camada antes prefeitura de
células solares porque a coisa mais
importante é quando a radiação solar
chega no meu dispositivo a maior parte
delas seja usada
portanto é bom que ela seja refletida eu
trabalhei eu estudei analisei a camada
antes refletora de células solares bom
acabei em uma estrada
vou fazer só mestrado carro que estava
parado e não comecei a pensar vou fazer
um doutorado porque vocês eu que messi é
da onu na faculdade fui fazer doutorado
mas eu queria fazer doutorado no
exterior
não você não vai poder fazer doutorado
no exterior
nessa época tinha em são carlos usp
sintusp pessoas em minha carreira em são
carlos estava lá uma pessoa muito
importante dentro do grupo de cientistas
italianos ele estava passando o ano
sabático aqui no brasil e foi para são
carlos e fahel júnior vai peitaria só
que naquela minha época a itália tinha
doutorado dele tcheca que não tinha o
que não era o nosso futuro então não
existiam doutorado realmente dito cnpq
uma 101 centro de fomento para bolsas e
me deu uma bolsa sanduíche eu fiz todos
os cursos aqui na usp de são carlos e
fui peitaria pra fazer o meu doutorado
mesmo só pesquisa fazia pesquisa
pesquisa pegar os dados voltar pra cá e
defendi aqui mas lá na itália conseguiu
uma bolsa maravilhosa para continuar
todo meu doutorado na inglaterra começar
tudo de novo na inglaterra então eu sou
doutora em semicondutores
eu trabalho em semicondutores pra micro
dispositivos sou mestre
sou mestre em semicondutores
me apaixonei por semicondutores mesmo
mestrado células solares é um
dispositivo semicondutor para a radiação
solar
fui fazendo doutorado em microeletrônica
meu estudo é a parte física não sou
engenheira eletrônica a parte física de
junções rasas junção é a cozinha que faz
o cm do condutor funcionar e quanto
menor ele é essa dimensão vocês estão
tendo agora numa época da
microeletrônica
mas agora o que existe é a nano
eletrônica que são 10 11 milhões de
vezes nem demissões menores entendeu
pois é eu sou física sou doutor eu tenho
phd na inglaterra em semicondutores
aí voltei para o brasil fui trabalhar no
centro técnico de informática em
campinas e em dispositivos me em dentro
da parte de microeletrônica desse centro
técnico da informática para analisarem
se tenha um microscópio maravilhoso você
põe o dispositivo microeletrónico lá
dentro liga faz um mix o dispositivo
funcionar eo microscópio mostra qual é a
linha que está funcionando ou não a
gente estudar melhorar melhorar o
desempenho melhorar o desenho etc
fiz concurso para ser professora e eu
sou professora de física no instituto
técnico da aeronáutica no centro técnico
aeroespacial em são josé dos campos
eu dou aula para os puros cabeçinhas das
do país porque só o ita tem esse curso
de tecnologia da aeronáutica só o ita
forma engenheiro aeronáutico engenheiro
eletrônico para aeronáutica engenharia
civil da era o porte engenharia da
computação pra tudo referente à defesa
haviam foguete satélite
ah e tem sempre uns que mecânica
mecânica de aviões
eu sonho do ita de física e outra coisa
imagina entanto que esses meninos que eu
digo menininhos porque a maioria é homem
até o ano 2000 mulher não podia nem
entrar na faculdade
que dirá quando foi fazer o concurso e
fiz um concurso em 93
eu perguntei eles não deixam mulher
assistiu o curso e deixa mulher da aula
não se pode fazer o concurso seja pré
sal não sei você pode fazer o concurso
eu passei então você imagina neto
sacrifício imaginação 5 mil
a meta são dez mil candidatos para
entrar em 120 vagas
no início da educação a quem não está
pra 400 mas isso envolve toda uma
infraestrutura que ele não está
conseguindo ainda então a meta para
alguns anos vai ser 4 foi vocês 400
engenheiros mas por enquanto 140 e 150
talvez a gente fica 200 agora no próximo
vestibular que agora a semana que vem
mas imagina essa professora que entrando
com esses meninos né que são super sumo
da redondinha e eles são taher eles
tenham uma cabeça eles eles não são
engenheiros se formam nesta faculdade
porque em cima são engenheiros você
diretor da embraer e você diretor do
facebook vão ser e põe tudo no masculino
porque são pouquíssimas as meninas é no
máximo 10% mas no primeiro ano que elas
entraram a número um e dentro das forças
armadas número significa melhor aluno
melhor nota melhor desempenho melhor
tudo
a número 1 foi mulher no primeiro ano
que as mulheres entraram e tem mais
em 2000 ela se formou com cinco anos
depois 2005 mas em 2000 apenas a número
1 foi uma mulher e nós já temos a
primeira mulher piloto e vou falar
piloto a presidenta etc porque nós
merecemos isso não importa que a palavra
não exista
nós temos mais é que criar essa palavra
porque não existe porque não existe a
pessoa agora existe nós temos mais o que
é alegado é a primeira a primeira piloto
já se formou na se formou há uns dois ou
três anos atrás então contando a partir
dali aqui 30 anos vamos ter a primeira
brincadeira porque é muito muito difícil
se torna brigadeiro brigadeiro mesmo
masculinos e não foi piloto sendo feitas
e não fez uma das melhores academias de
aeronáutica no país
se você é piloto e você face taha conta
assim os 25 anos brincadeira com certeza
é muito complicados e brigadeiro tá
quem tem que nomear é o presidente mas
se ela continuar nessa começa nessa
carreira
nós vamos ter uma brincadeira daqui uns
25 anos mais ou menos
mas é isso seriam adivinhar o que eu sou
adoro
saímos em quatro escolas de samba
fundada por carnaval
mas se eu contar isso na escola de samba
correta isso acredito mas não acreditava
inicialmente é bom
além disso desvio na minha cozinha eu
copero com a universidade zumbi dos
palmares e o governo federal está
precisando de engenheiros para ontem
eles estão no desespero pra tudo isso
que está acontecendo novo no país estão
importando engenheiros então governo
federal criou a bolsa ciência sem
fronteira
é isso pessoal estudar lá fora o que
eles não conseguem estudar aqui você
conseguir a bolsa ciência sem fronteiras
tem que ter 600 pontos dentro da da do
enem com 600 pontos você pode pedir uma
bolsa sem fronteira de seis pessoas que
conseguiram 600 pontos no enem do ano
passado 54% eram negros 54% pergunta
quantos por cento conseguiu pegar uma
bolsa ciência sem fronteira 3% são
negros que foram daí os negros todos que
estão querendo essa bolsa foram lá briga
na brasília e certa não foram recebidos
nem pelo ministro nem nada
a presidenta estava no haiti nos estados
unidos eo pessoal ajudantes negro se
acorrentaram e disseram nós também
queremos a bolsa tirar um foto mandaram
pelo facebook o reitor no haiti recebeu
no celular zinho dele essa foto e
mostrou que dilma dilma qual é que tá
acontecendo vocês não gostam de negros
no brasil
bom dilma ligou a quem de direito existe
uma cota agora até os negros só que essa
informação também foi pelas
universidades principalmente negros nos
estados unidos que são universidades de
mais de 100 75 anos formaram a outra
formar um presidentes da república
africano formaram gente muito importante
então criança gente assim né
são negros a usp não quer da cota
honesto não quer da cota
nós queremos essa gente pra cá bom
qualquer o primeiro principal desculpa
do ministro não querer receber esses
negros não queria receber nada
os negros não sabe falar inglês ele já
tenha contemplação para completar o
vestibular ruim escola pública não é boa
nem aqui e nem ele sabia frente
quem é que consegue falar passar no
exame tóquio que você tem que usar o
exame e tóquio para conseguir a bolsa da
c 130 para os estados unidos
quem é negro que conta em inglês
suficiente para fazer isso é bom
mercadante é dar uma boa para aumentar o
número de bolsas nas universidades
negras estão mandando gente para cá pra
ensinar inglês para os brasileiros
o pessoal às missas negras decidiram os
dos negros podem vir pra cá a bolsa
sempre vai ter que aumentar seis meses
nessas bolsas eles ficam seis meses aqui
aprendendo inglês
e aí que eles começam a fazer o curso
que geram fazer maravilha maravilha dos
300 brasileiros que já foram para as
bolsas pretas universidades
principalmente negras que está recebendo
brasileiros em inglês já foram
presidentes brasileiros pela pergunta
quanto de 300 quantos são negros
cinco são negros nas universidades
negras vieram aqui que teve uma reunião
nessa e em palmares e o pessoal da
universidade daqui a pouco ela é este aí
pois nem reduzir em efraim do mundo de
branco fica até engraçado porque eu
estava esperando nem dos brasileiros
bom no dia 18 de novembro mercadante foi
nessa reunião nos humildes formais e
assinou uma bolsa
abdias nascimento só para negros só para
negros negros e agora é o meu maior só
eu quero cooperar é porque eu tenho um
lugarzinho no inferno que as mulheres
têm ajudado é eu gostaria de dar negros
e negras pode ser homem também mas em
todo caso dessa universidade zumbi dos
palmares 54 por cento são mulheres então
provavelmente está ajudando mais
mulheres
o meu sonho eu gostaria muito de
comunicar isso ao mercadante a quem de
direito
eu gostaria de fazer parte dessa
comissão que define quem vai fazer obter
essas bolsas porque essas bolsas e pode
até perder a doação visto que as
universidades universidade de engenharia
aqui os pionés que eu sei lá mais qual
não tem cota não quer da cota não quer
negócio lá deixa esta negada toda está
nos estados unidos
aprender lá vai voltar com o inglês
se a bárbara o meu sonho e eu não quero
esse lugarzinho no inferno eu quero
ajudar sim eu gostaria muito de fazer
parte dessa comissão que vai definir
quem é negro suficiente para obter sua
bolsa e daqui a pouco vai estar só
branco pegando essa bolsa de negro da
empresa universidades
muito obrigada é só isso que eu queria